briefly I was doing a phone call last
chance harvey with emma thompson a few
years ago the cinematographer was John
de Borman who shot this we became
friends while we were shooting and at
one point he said can't you have these
ideas you should punish it direct and I
said well if you come up with something
you know let me know and i think i went
three years ago maybe next week i called
to wish him a happy new year and i said
again if you hear something let me know
hung up the phone five minutes later
literally he said the producer of this
it was also the producer of an education
which he also shot Finola Dwyer called
him and said that her second director
just fell out she had a script if he
knows of anybody he read it he sent it
to me i read it on the airplane and that
was it so when I came to it a Maggie was
already with it Courtney was already
with it and you know Harwood the the
writer had done the dresser with Albert
Finney and with Courtney and that's how
they had met and and Courtney who still
takes credit for this said he said to
Harwood please find something else for
Finney and I to do Finney was supposed
to do the wolf part but he became ill so
by the time I came on board Maggie was
already with it i think Harwood wrote it
with her in mind they've been these
people known each other for 50 years and
so all I had to do was in terms of the
principles I i I've you know I cast a
billy connolly and and he didn't want to
do it he thought he said who's in it I
said Maggie Smith Tom Cortese legends I
can't do this he says I'm not an actor
Isis know you are I see mrs. Brown I
said you held your own with Judi Dench
so he was talked into it and and then I
asked Maggie and it's interesting
because I've been doing this for
whatever almost 50 years now
and it's always amazed me that directors
don't ask the actors that are in the
same film that they're directing who do
you think is right for this part you
know I wish they would more often so I
didn't know Maggie and I was working
here so I called her in London and I
said by the way do you have any idea of
who should play the part of a [ __ ] and
without a pause she said Pauline Collins
and I'm ashamed to say that I hadn't
seen Shirley Valentine which I then saw
and I thought she was extraordinary so
she cast Pauline and then I talked to
them as a group and I suggested I said I
don't think you guys should play
characters quote unquote I said I think
you should be very close to yourself and
we're all in the same boat role in our
70s we've all been doing this for 40 45
50 years and we noticed the changes not
only in ourselves but in terms of being
able to get parts and what it feels like
to be where we are now is the greatest
service that we can give the audience so
can we be courageous enough to allow
that to be on screen Maggie plays a diva
but she plays a diva who's no longer a
diva and I googled these people as much
as possible uh though I hate the 21st
century for this some of these things
but in the London Times a few years ago
she was very candid and she said she
wasn't going to act anymore at the time
of the interview she said she's very
open she said she was getting radiation
chemotherapy she didn't have the energy
anymore nor the desire and she said
that's it and in fact the interviewer
said in that interview but you have your
future you your whole future she said
most of its being and I said Maggie you
have to put that line in the film which
she does and I said this
is what I mean and the hip is maggie
maggie has a hit is as a bad hip so
that's its its its merged into it uh and
she didn't act for maybe two three years
and then suddenly she comes back and she
hasn't stopped and that's the movie